et chose au réseau à l'étranger après
plus d'une décennie de tension et de
négociation les espoirs de résoudre la
crise du nucléaire iranien se concentre
à lausanne en suisse et pourparlers
entre l'iran et les cinq membres du
conseil permanent de sécurité plus
l'allemagne semble avoir progressé ce
soir l'objectif c'est de réduire les
capacités nucléaires de l'iran pour
l'empêcher de fabriquer une bombe
atomique et en échange la communauté
internationale doit lever les sanctions
qui étouffent l'économie iranienne
les discussions tournent autour de trois
grands points la durée de l'accord
d'abord les etats-unis se contenterait
par exemple de 10 ans le calendrier de
levée des sanctions téhéran exige la
levée immédiate mais les occidentaux
sont méfiants et puis à le contrôler la
vérification des installations
nucléaires iraniennes par les
inspecteurs de l'agencé internationale
de l'énergie atomique
j'en parle avec notre correspondant à
washington christian n'y aura pas
d'entendre ce soir la date butoir est
passée mais on continue de discuter
tumen ya eu du mouvement
beaucoup de mouvements suisse céline le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov qui mentionne que les
pays occidentaux et l'iran seraient
venus à une entente de principe
le ministre iranien des affaires
étrangères monsieur arif qui mentionne
qu'on serait prêts même a commencé à
rédiger cette entente de principe dès
demain le président obama ici à
washington qui est actuellement réuni au
moment où on se parle avec son conseil
national de sécurité
donc ça bouge ça bouge beaucoup et ça
semble bouger dans le bon sens puisque
ces négociations sont très importantes
si line pour les américains et également
les européens
c'est la première fois qu'on est si près
de s'entendre avec l'iran on veut garder
l'iran à l'oeil parce qu'on ne croie pas
le régime de téhéran
lorsqu'on mentionne là-bas que le
programme de développement nucléaire et
seulement civiles et non militaires des
négociations des pourparlers qui sont
cruciales pour les iraniens également
parce qu'on sait que les sanctions
internationales et wrangler économie
depuis plusieurs années et ça empêche
des milliards de dollars de rentrées
dans le pays donc terrain exige la levée
des sanctions
en échange d'inspection
ont beaucoup plus rigoureuse beaucoup
plus fréquente est ce qu'on va donner
accès aux inspecteurs de l'onu
c'est là que tout se joue c'est donc ça
fait quand même 12 ans qui à ce bras de
fer diplomatique et ça semble le plus
réaliste aujourd'hui de penser qu'on va
vraiment parvenir à s'entendre
ben écoutez il faut pas être naïf non
plus on parle d'une entente de principe
il ya personne de sérieux ce soir qui ne
s'attend à ce que l'entente soit totale
et définitive
mais comme vous le voyez on se parle on
se parle encore et ça c'est très bon
signe pour kouassi les repas dans
l'entente définitive parce que ces
choses là sont très compliquées il ya
encore beaucoup de méfiance également de
part et d'autre mais on parle d'une
entente davantage définitive pour la fin
du mois de juin
il faut dire que s'il n'y avait pas
d'accord les conséquences pourraient
être très graves mais écoutez pour le
président obama qui a mis tout son poids
dans la balance tout son poids dans ces
négociations
il risque de perdre la face quoi qu'il
ne veut pas accepter n'importe quoi
l'iran pourrait continuer de développer
son programme nucléaire et qui sait
peut-être éventuellement même
probablement être capable de développer
la fameuse bande de la fabrique et
l'iran qui subirait encore les sanctions
économiques
et qui sait peut-être la guerre des
attaques ciblées par les israéliens et
les américains éventuellement sur des
sites nucléaires iraniens bref ce soir
le monde serait probablement un endroit
un peu plus sécuritaire avec que sans un
accord avec l'iran doute alors on en
saura certainement un peu plus au cours
des prochaines heures merci beaucoup
christian au revoir bonne soirée